And now it's the old scout master.
So a boy scout, a girl scout, a rabbi, a priest and a politician walk into the bar and the
bartender looks at them and says, hey, is this some kind of joke?
Oh, that's the best I can do today.
Hey, this is podcast number 364..
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green
And we're still talking fundamentals, foundations, the basics,
And I've been asking for you to get in touch with me and let me know what you think.
And this past week I heard from Tom Finnan, who is the scout master with Troop 500 in
St Louis,
And Tom said these are great podcasts
Overall. I could not agree with you more on them as first principles sorts of ideas.
I appreciate the metaphoric language on things.
That's the only way I can wrap my head around some of this stuff. being somewhat new to scout
master ship,
I have a couple of things to mention based on scouts in our troop and students that I
work with as a college professor.
One, kids really don't know how to play without organization imposed on them.
Two, sports aren't what they used to be.
Three, kids are stuck on screens more than their parents appreciate.
I have a number of experiences when we go camping, where I have opted to allow the
scouts just to simply play around inventing a game of some strange sort, simply because
they never get that opportunity otherwise.
One of the great things we can do for scouts is to introduce them to playing
Well. thanks, Tom,
I'm glad you're enjoying these podcasts.
So I agree and disagree with you at the same time.
Anytime in human history we could sit down as the older generation and look at the
newer generation and make some judgments about the way that they are, that we find
difficult or unacceptable or sad or deficient in some way in comparison with ourselves.
I'm not saying those observations in general or the particular observations that you
make are invalid or unimportant, but just that we should put them in context, because
you know, part of the founding of the scouting movement was dealing with the perceived
difficulties and problems and deficiencies in the youth of that time period, which
always gives me a chuckle, right? because? because there's another way of looking at
the world that says, well, that was the good old days.
The context that I want to lend to that is: yeah, I understand what you're saying
and it's not invalid, but we also have to understand that our perspective is going
to warp the way that those things look to us.
Do young people today not know how to play without organization and post on them?
Well, I don't know,
Maybe they have more of a propensity for organized play,
Maybe there's more adult involvement in their lives.
So their lives are different from ours.
Yeah, is that a bad thing?
I'm not sure.
Are sports any different than they used to be?
Well, I coached wrestling for a number of years- and I know you know
there was- that was 25 years ago- and there were always those teams and coaches
in that philosophy of winning at all costs, focusing only on this,
And this had to be your whole life.
So I don't know if that's significantly changed. screen time and the way
that young people relate to technology and the Internet is a big concern.
Television was a big concern when I was growing up.
Radio was a big concern when my father was growing up.
Comic books were a big concern when my older brother was growing up,
You know. so I'm just a little reticent to claim these things
as a great deal of motivation in the way that I work scouting.
Not that they're untrue, not that they're invalid,
not that we shouldn't be concerned, but we've always been concerned.
And the right answer. you know, the antidote to the excesses and vicissitudes
of young people has always pretty much been the same, you know,
and that's caring about them, being compassionate and loving,
mentoring them, coaching them, working with them and scouts
working with them in any way possible.
That just seems to be the way to work right.
I do appreciate your comments
and thank you for getting in touch.
So, without much further ado,
I think we should move on to the fourth in our foundation series.
So let's get started. shall we
Jump up and scream and shout it out:
Lookin' good in my uniform.
Because, baby, I was born to be a scout,
Because, baby, I was born to be a.
Here comes the scout master.
Drive a jungle scout, roll me a little faster,
Stick on the gas. are we there? yet
I wanna build a bridge for my eagle.
Today we're in our fourth of the foundational series,
the Fundamental Series,
And in the first one in podcast- I think it was 361,
we talked about scouting as a game And in a small digression, let's remind ourselves that analogies
take something that we know to explain something that we don't know. So when we say scouting is a
game, we're not literally saying that scouting is a game. We're saying it's like a game. You need
to remember that analogies will break at a certain point because scouting is its own thing. It's
not actually a game, but it's very much like one. What scouting holds in common with games?
it has a set of rules that define the game. Some of these rules are found in the policies and
procedures of a scouting organization, but most, the most important ones, are just the fundamental,
foundational things. that is the subject of our discussion over these past podcasts.
One significant thing about scouting that is different from most games is that it's not a
competition other than the individual challenge involved. Scouting has strategies and methods.
It has a field of play and that's going camping. It has a set of specific skills that, while
practical in the outside world, are mostly practical within the construct of the game. It has a goal,
which is the development of character in scouts by applying the patrol method, And we need to
remember that it is an imperfectible game. It has, theoretically you could have perfect scouting
and it's always something to aim at without being frustrated by the fact, while it is theoretically
a perfectible game, like all games, it is practically imperfectible. So we are not perturbed,
put off, angered, set off by the imperfections that we will see as the game progresses.
In the podcast after that we talked about our role in scouting, the scouter's role in scouting as
being like the coaches of a game, And we talked about the importance of perspective. We talked
about the importance of observation, of dialogue and two main types of dialogue. The most under
valued and, to my mind, most important is inquiry, asking questions, And then there's also the
directive kind of thing that coaches do. that kind of dialogue And dialogue means it's more
than you talking right. There has to be something receptive on the other end if you're going to have
dialogue. We talked about coaches facilitating discovery- not leading everything, but facilitating
the discovery of things- And we also talked about responsive leadership, responsive mentorship,
responsive coaching that assesses the skills and development of our players or scouts and
responds appropriately. And then in the last podcast we talked about the players, We talked about
our relationship to them, And in this podcast we're going to talk about playing the game.
So one of the kind of guiding concepts here is that this game of scouting has a field of
play. If you were to visit a basketball court or a soccer field, you would see
markings that define the field of play And in scouting we don't have markings on the ground,
We don't have chalk lines on the field, We don't have tape marks on the basketball court,
But we have a definite field of play. Learning where the lines are is one of the great things
about being a scouter. It's going to take some time. You're going to experiment, You're
going to work on things and you will learn what I'm talking about. You'll learn where the
lines are on the field because players play the game, Coaches don't play the game, Parents don't
play the game. In most organized games, if the coach goes on the field, things go bad.
The ref stopped the game, They warn the coach And if the coach repeats that behavior gets
thrown out of the game. So learning where the lines are and your role, your perspective,
is important And sticking with the game's analogy here, some things about scouting we look at as flaws
are actually features of the game. There are things that can't be fixed or altered and they
shouldn't be fixed or altered And if you don't see that, you'll spend a whole lot of energy
trying to fix things that are actually features of the game. So understanding scouting in this
context means that efficiency and practicality and logic is sometimes not the answer,
Because, putting aside anything you might know about basketball, for instance- and it was your
job to make that the most efficient exercise ever- you would look at it and see a number of flaws
in the way that the game is played. The goal of the game of basketball is passing the ball
through the hoop more times than the opposing team. So you wouldn't want a hoop that's 10 feet off the
ground. You wouldn't want it that small. You wouldn't want a ball that big. You would change
those aspects of the game to make it easier to get the ball through the hoop as many times as
possible, If that's the goal of the game. But the challenge is created by putting the hoop
10 feet off the ground, making sure the rim is 18 inches in diameter, making sure that you're
using a regulation basketball, because those aspects of the game create the challenge that is
necessary for the game to exist. So working with in scouting, keep those things in mind, because
things like working with scouts under their own leadership in patrols is not very efficient.
Now there's a part of our practical, logical minds that looks at that situation
and it depends on where you come from, If you know business, if you know education.
if you know the military, you look at the idea that you have, oh, let's say, 40 some scouts in a
troop and they're all divided up in patrols. And the reason that you haven't divided in patrols
is management Taking the big group, dividing it into smaller groups, making it more manageable.
Well, that is not the point, is it? The point is, within the patrol, within that small group
concept, our scouts are able to go through a number of experiences that create the opportunity
for them to grow in character by applying the ideals of the scout, oath and law.
Another important way to look at playing the game is the idea that our goal the development
of character in the individual scout- let's call that a figurative goal, Okay, because we tend to
like things to be practical, logical and literal- And the development of character
in an individual scout is rather impractical, sometimes illogical and it's very subjective.
So our goal is kind of figurative. Our scouts view their time in scouting and the things that they
want to do very literally. They want to go camping with their pals, They want to learn
certain skills, They want to have certain experiences. Those are very literal goals
for them And we want them to accomplish those goals. At the same time, we want to keep in
mind our figurative goal. And if you do this while you're playing the game, it's going to take a lot
of the pressure off, Because the point is not the development of skill. Skill is an indicator.
The point is not racking up nights of camping. nights of camping are an indicator. The point
is not advancement and advancing in rank and getting a lot of merit badges. Those are indicators.
They're important indicators, but they only indicate that we are advancing towards the
ultimate goal of the game, which is the development of character in the individual scout.
Because one way of looking at it is all of the things in scouting, all of the camping and the
skills and the advancement, the uniforms, all of the trappings right, All of the window dressing,
as I am fond of saying, is a massive head fake. If you're not familiar with a head fake,
think about basketball for a moment. You're in control of the ball, You want to move it
down the court, You look one way, you move your head one way while you move your body the other way,
tricking the defensive player into moving in the direction. you move your head while you move
your body in the other way, And that's kind of what's happening in scouting. Young people are
attracted to the ideas of going camping, of learning skills, of these achievements and
things, but we know that they are only a means to an end. They are not an end in themselves.
Step back for a moment and look at the whole scene with me. Where do we apply our energy?
Where do we apply our time? Where do we develop our expertise? Do we develop it in the things that
are the indicators of the game, Or do we develop it in the direction of the ultimate goal?
Interesting thought, isn't it? If we are focused on the things that only indicate that we're
getting towards the goal, and not the goal itself, we're going to grow frustrated. So if you are
frustrated with scouts, if you're frustrated with the members of your pack, your den, your troop,
your patrol, your crew, that is an indication that maybe you have got your focus, your perspective,
in the wrong place. Now, should a scouter ever be frustrated? Well, of course you should be,
because it's frustrating work and just the nature of the game and all these things that we keep in
mind and you have to balance. it's frustrating. And then we're working with young people in
different stages of development, with different sets of skills who happen to have parents, and
we're not working in a vacuum, because we have a broader culture and we have all the other things
that are in young people's lives to consider. but when you focus on the ultimate goal- the development
of character in an individual scout- all of the window dressing and all of the other concerns
begin to fade in the background and you have a clarity of mission, You have a way to play this
game and you will do a lot of good. And again we kind of return to the idea of your perspective
and how important that is, because there is something about scouting that you ought to
understand: It always works, It never fails, It always, always works. The difficulty is
we don't often appreciate how it works. When you're actually doing scouting, you are doing good.
When you're trying to develop skills or check off requirements or impose regimentation on a group
of young people, you're not really doing scouting. When you're trying to develop the character
of an individual scout, it always works and you're doing good. Now I'm not saying that these
other things are totally unimportant. All I'm saying is is that to get the right perspective
to make this rewarding and fun for you as a scouter, as well as benefit the young people that
you're serving. you have to understand that scouting always works. You are always moving the ball
forward. You are always adding something to a young person's life. Now there's this whole
culture, this whole philosophy around games that winning is the only thing that you can do. You
have to win, You have to score more points. There's this idea that if everybody gets a ribbon,
nobody wins. Just forget about all that. It's a bankrupt philosophy. It's a zero-sum way of
looking at the world and you can't bring that into scouting and be successful. What you have
to look for is progress. It may be very small and it may be very hard to find, but it is there
because scouting always works. This has been a lot of philosophical kind of big picture talk.
Let's get down to brass tacks. Let me give you some practical advice. Some step one,
two and three advice. Here it is: Go camping. Scouting is camping. Scouting is in the outdoors.
it's setting up tents. it's building fires. it's cooking outdoors. It's learning the skills needed
to be comfortable to deal with the situations around you. It's playing games. in the outdoors
It is. It's laying in a sunny field for an hour in the afternoon. It's running around in the
woods with your pals. It's putting a backpack on your back and walking 10 miles in a weekend.
It's getting into a canoe for a week and heading out into the wilderness. It's
challenging yourself mentally, physically and spiritually to undertake these things
in an environment that's unfamiliar, under your own leadership, making it happen. So step one,
two and three is going camping. This isn't about nostalgia or back to basics or yearning for
simplicity. This is the field of play. This is where we do the game, And there are all kinds
of other distractions that have been brought into scouting over the years that are likely very
beneficial to young people, you know. but the big thing is getting out and going camping and doing
it with your patrol. Working with younger children in Cubs is going camping, not as much as older
children do, but what you're aiming at is building the dynamic of the small group,
of building social skills and interpersonal skills, of learning through doing games and things and
learning through skills that are ultimately leading to getting in the out of doors and going
camping. You might say that this is a very limited view, that I'm being overly simplistic.
You might say that I am eliminating a lot of opportunities and things like that,
but we have a field of play, and that field of play is camping, And the reason that it is
is because when you go camping, it requires you to rebuild civilization from the ground up.
Your small group is given a little plot of land to build on to guard yourself from the
elements, to make sure that you're fed, to make sure that you're safe and comfortable,
to make sure that you're warm, And all of the thousands of little things that happen in
accomplishing that is what builds character in Scouts, And it's not like being freezing, cold
and wet. It's not suffering alone that builds character, Although you know, this is going to
be challenging for a lot of young people. and that's good. That challenge is great because
you push yourself a little bit. But, like I said, it's all of those thousands and thousands of
little tiny things that happen. The interactions between Scouts, the development of skills, the
trying to figure things out and rebuild the world is what's important. The fringe benefit is that
we're outdoors in the natural world and all the wonderful things that means. But the point,
the big goal, getting the ball through the hoop, is the development of character,
And that's where it happens in Scouting. Now you're going to tell me that not all young
people want to go camping. That's fine. Not all young people are Scouts, And I am.
I'm fine with that. You're going to tell me that all young people today don't want to go camping,
that they're just a bunch of couch potatoes who like to play their video games and things.
Well, I'm sorry, but that's a very bankrupt way of looking at the world. Over 100 years ago,
Baden Powell had this germ of an idea that has developed and grown And it still works
the same way that it did 100 years ago, Not out of nostalgia, not out of blind tradition
and the yearning to go back to the good old days, but because it simply works. Now, most
of the Scouts that I've worked with over the past 30 years are not big on camping as adults,
And that's fine. A lot of them are. But my point was not to try and make them campers.
My point was not to try and make them skilled in woodcraft. My point was not to make them
experts in first aid. My point was not to make them Eagle Scouts. My point is to make them grow
in character by inculcating the ideals of the Scout oath and law. So my practical advice
to you: if you want to play the game. you've got to go camping. It's pretty simple, isn't it?
Because everything else flows out of that. All of the other things that we do- patrol meetings
and troop meetings and instructional sessions and merit badges, and all of that other stuff-
is all aimed at getting outdoors into a tent and going camping. How about that?
I'll tell you what I really think next time. No, I mean, I don't want to be preachy, I don't
want to be overly simplistic And I'm not trying to make anybody feel bad, But you know,
this is the point of the whole exercise. This is our field of play, This is playing the game.
So let's see if we can wrap the past four podcasts into one thought. Okay,
Scouting is a game that's played in the outdoors. Scouts are like coaches. Scouts are like players.
The coaches goal is the development of character in the individual scout. The scout's goal is to
go camping with their friends and to discover their capabilities and strengths, to discover
new skills and interesting things and to have fun experiences. And all of this happens when we
focus on our field of play, that is, getting out and going camping. So, as I've said before,
I'm very interested to hear from you. I'd love to hear your thoughts on all of this,
And it's easy to get in touch with me, And I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thank you so much for listening to this 364th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast. Please
get in touch. It's easy to do. Just go to scoutmastercgcom and use the contact link that
you'll find up there in the menu at the top of the page, Or you can just email me directly at
Clark at scoutmastercgcom. That's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom. I really ought to tell you that
I am not endorsed or sponsored by any scouting organization, including the Boy Scouts of America.
You know, it's just me doing my best, trying to help my fellow scouters, And I want to make
sure to thank all of the patrons and backers who make the podcast and the blog possible.
You can join them. It's easy to do. Again, go to scoutmastercgcom, look for the support links at
the top of the page there and get details on exactly how to make that happen. And finally,
we need to hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir. Until next time, everyone.